Hey everybody, hey.
It’s been five years since Elon Musk
first showed off Tesla’s solar roof tiles.
You’ll want to call your neighbors over
and say, ‘check out this sweet roof.’”
Yet five years later, they
are far from mainstream.
Unlike Tesla’s other offering
of large solar panels,
these tiles are made to look like normal roofing
shingles that generate electricity for your home.
Getting into the business of
making them was controversial.
Tesla shareholders sued Musk for buying the
solar panel company founded by his cousins,
SolarCity, for $2.6 billion alleging
it amounted to a bailout for his
family of which. He was also the
largest shareholder of SolarCity.
So Musk bet big on these tiles.
But their deployment has fallen from the
highs of 2017, although it appears to be
picking up recently. Tesla notes 2021 saw a 68%
increase in megawatts deployed year over year.
However, although Tesla claimed it could
manufacture 1,000 solar tile roofs a week,
Bloomberg reported that the company could
barely manage 200 weekly installs in 2021.
I’ve reached out to Tesla for the
latest figures but haven't heard back.
Turns out, it’s been harder to
install the roofs than Tesla imagined.
“…we are choked at the installation point.
We basically made some significant mistakes
in assessing the difficulty of certain roofs.
The complexity of roofs varies dramatically. So
you just can’t have a one
size fits all situation.”
Tesla installs some roofs themselves and at
other times, relies on third-party installers.
So the big thing with Tesla’s solar
roof is the complexity factor.
CJ McConaghy is the owner of Three Tree Roofing,
a certified Tesla roof
installer in the Seattle area.
The plans that we get, that we design
for the roof, it looks like a lego kit.
Just like a lego set, all the pieces
have to fit together perfectly.
The wiring is also very complex.
This isn’t something we deal with with any
other kind of roof. Dealing with the tiles,
handling them because it’s glass.
They’re also pretty slippery.
There are just a lot more moving pieces to
this type of roofing than a traditional roof.
So if a traditional roof, the kind
that most houses currently have,
takes three days to install,
how long does a Tesla roof take?
That’s a great question.
If it’s a moderate to easy
roof design the Tesla solar roof is
going to be more like 10 to 12 days.
Given the unforeseen complexities, Tesla hiked the
prices of its roofs which really upset customers.
And got slapped with a class-action
lawsuit in California last year
led by a customer who said his contract got
increased from $71,000 to a whopping $146,000!
Tesla then told customers’ attorneys it would
reverse the hike for those who
had already signed contracts.
So, how much could you expect to pay
for one of these roofs right now?
That depends on many factors: where you
live, the size of your home, its age.
As an example, Tesla’s order page shows a
2000-square foot home in Las Vegas with an average
electricity bill of $135 a month is estimated to
cost $57,300 before the U.S. federal tax credit.
Tesla notes the price can vary up
to $12,000 depending on complexity.
To try to entice more people
to choose their roofs,
Tesla recently announced a 20-year loan option
so customers can pay for their system over time.
A big reason Tesla hasn’t done more
to boost its solar business – is
because its primary focus is on
mass-producing electric cars.
Tesla went through hell in 2018 trying to churn
out its most affordable car yet, the Model 3.
So it was all hands on deck to crank out as many
cars as possible and solar took a back seat.
“We had to basically take the whole
company including a bunch of people
that were on solar (and) have them work on cars.”
Not only did Tesla divert staff
it also fired solar executives.
Bloomberg reported that Musk dismissed
both the head of Tesla Energy, RJ Johnson,
and Ryan Nungesser, the director of operations at
Tesla’s Buffalo factory where the tiles are made.
And now, the focus is on Model Y production
at two new gigafactories: in Texas and Berlin.
Even with so much on its plate, Tesla
likely won’t give up on its solar ambitions.
Because it’s a way to show the world
that it’s more than a car company but
one that intends to lead the
transition to clean energy.
And I hope you agree that’s the future we want.
Solar is an integral part of
its clean energy ecosystem.
The energy produced from the roof
is stored in the Tesla powerwall,
which can power your home during an
outage or charge your electric car.
It’s an obvious three-part solution.
Except two parts are still missing.
Not only the solar tiles.
But also, powerwall production
has lagged behind which Musk
blames on chip shortages due to the pandemic.
Tesla acknowledges its solar division has
work to do. It wrote in its fourth-quarter
earnings report that it plans on
“...making further cost improvements…”
It appears to be making
progress in that direction.
Tesla has launched an updated solar roof
tile with a 23% higher power capacity
without increasing the tile size according
to a spec sheet obtained by Electrek.
So fewer solar tiles would be
needed since each roof uses a mix
of tiles - some with and without solar
cells although they all look the same.
Fewer solar tiles mean fewer electrical
connections which can bring down the cost.
Although Tesla’s solar roofs have yet to take
off, Musk says he’s confident it will happen.
I think it will not be long before Tesla
is by far the market leader in solar.
So, I’ve been looking for an
exciting investment for 2022
and a revolutionary platform offers one
that really caught my eye: Masterworks.io
Masterworks gives you the chance to
invest in famous paintings by Picasso,
Monet, and Banksy by buying
shares in these artworks.
Why art? Art has outpaced the S&P 500 from 1995
to 2021 and has almost no correlation with stocks.
Is it legit? Yes! Masterworks
is the first company to offer
paintings filled with the Securities and
Exchange Commission as public offerings.
Is anyone doing it? Yes, they are. Over
300,000 investors have already signed up.
One of their latest offerings
by Banksy sold out in under
three hours! Masterworks flipped another
painting by the famous street artist for a 32%
return in 2020, and George Condo's Staring into
Space gave investors a 31% return last year.
There’s a lot of demand to invest
in art and often a waiting period,
but you can get priority access by heading
to my custom link in the description.
Which also supports this channel.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.